vous vous souvenez sans doute de
l'histoire de jean dominique bauby
ce journaliste atteint d'une paralysie
totale qui ne communiquait plus que par
clignements de paupières
il avait raconté son histoire est bien
ce livre le scaphandre et le papillon a
été adapté au cinéma et c'est le
deuxième film français en compétition à
cannes sur place pascal deschamps
michael cariou docteur soit une point
tout ça est difficile pour vous pour
nous tout n'est pas rose le film s'ouvre
sur un battement de paupière c'est
désormais la seule partie du corps de
jean dominique bauby qui fonctionne et
ce sera désormais sa seule façon de
communiquer c'est que vous pouvez
cligner des yeux
alors vous avez cligner une fois pour
wii 2 fois pour nous jean dominique
bauby le vrai le voile a filmé à
l'hôpital de berck dans les mois qui ont
précédé sa mort c'est là qu'il a
patiemment dictée en battant des cils
pour chaque lettre désirer le livre dont
est tiré le film aux riches ap à son
scaphandre
il a ainsi choisi de laisser voguer son
esprit tel un papillon
au fil de ses souvenirs quand adam de
ses regrets blanche
les chances qu'on n'a pas voulu saisir
les instants de bonheur on m'a laissé
s'envoler
c'était j'avais dessous ou bien avait-il
nécessairement la lumière d'un malheur
pour m'éclairer sur ma vraie nature une
fois qu'il a décidé d'écrire ce livre
il a pu vraiment faire le point et
construire quelque chose qui lui a donné
l'envié de vie je suppose que même une
ébauche une ombre un beau de papa c'est
encore un papa
mathieu amalric compose sans chercher la
performance à tout prix un personnage
parfois désespérés parfois drôle mais
toujours bouleversant dont les
réflexions sont une immense leçon des
vies n'a envie de l'instant on a envie
de regarder les choses de profiter du
goût de l'odorat des cinq sens du
toucher du corps un film qui ne devrait
laisser personne indifférent et surtout
pas le jury
dommage armes